Selena Gomez didn't keep her hands to
herself on a date night with Drew
Taggart can't keep my hands to myself
check out the actress and The
Chainsmokers singer holding hands
leaving dinner at a restaurant in New
York City Saturday night sells rocking
in all Black Ensemble as he wears a more
casual look in jeans and a hoodie both
clearly keeping each other close for the
outing
Selena and Drew's night out comes just
days after E.T confirmed the two are
dating
you never know who you're going to make
magic with so so how did they meet well
the source tells E.T it was through
mutual friends in a friendly low-key way
but they had an instant connection and
liked each other as people quote they
have been talking ever since and they're
into each other I think it's nice to
have a little bit something to myself
but despite the fact that sell and Drew
are seeing each other she's clearing one
thing up she's still single I'm very
honest though in general a day after
news broke of their Romance the singer
shared this cryptic photo that says I
like being alone too much the hashtag I
am single
[Music]
Selena Andrew first sparked dating
rumors when page six published pics of
the two on a bowling date in the Big
Apple and eyewitness claims they were
making out between strikes oh my
goodness yeah just last month A source
told E.T Selena was feeling positive and
optimistic about her love life and that
she was open to dating I'm constantly
somebody that likes to grow and feel
like all right what could I be better at
what could I do better at where where
could my confidence be stronger and it
seems things are going well between
Selena and Drew as another source says
that although things are still new
they're having so much fun getting to
know one another
[Music]
thank you